[موسيقى]
بصراحة ، أحب العطور
كثيرًا وأريد أن أرى الجميع يحبون
استخدام العطر كشكل من أشكال حب الذات
لأنه حقًا
ترتديه وتشعر بتحسن وتشعر
بمزيد من الثقة وتشعر بمزيد من السعادة ،
أنا مونيكا تان أنا زميل  -مؤسس
هدى بيوتي ومؤسس عطور k Ali ،
مرحبًا بكم في مكتبة العطور الخاصة بي ، لدينا
الآلاف من العطور هنا ، لقد
فقدت العد مرة أخرى ، أحتاج إلى العد مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
روائح جيدة جدًا ، سأرش مثل 20
بحلول الوقت  المغادرة من هنا ،
لقد أثرتني دبي في كل
طريقة من خلال رحلة العطور هذه
لأنني بصراحة لا أعتقد أنني سأقوم
بإنشاء علامة تجارية للعطور إذا لم
أتحرك
هنا ، فقد كان هذا مصدر إلهام كبير
لمختبر Oula هو عطر رائع حقًا
مساحة إنشاء حيث يمكنك الذهاب وإنشاء
العطور الخاصة بك
[الموسيقى]
لديهم الكثير من عناصر القائمة المختلفة
حيث يمكنك اتباع وصفة مختلفة
ولكني أحب الذهاب إلى هناك
وإنشاء اختلاطاتي الخاصة فقط
لذا سنبدأ بـ
الملاحظات الأساسية  وقد أذهب قليلاً إلى المارقة ،
سأقوم فقط بإنشاء أشياء من
الصفر وبعد ذلك سأضيف
القليل من
المفاجآت التي تعرفها هنا وهناك
لأنني أحب إضافة القليل من
التوابل قليلاً من النكهة
لذلك دعونا نبدأ المسك هو
بالتأكيد أمر لا بد منه
[موسيقى]
الآن سأضيف بعضًا من الروعة ،
إنه شيء نحبه حقًا هنا
في المنطقة ويجعل عطورك
تدوم
طويلاً وهو ما أحبه بعد الانتقال إلى
دبي.  كان
حبي للعطور تمامًا مثل
المنجنيق يرجع جزئيًا إلى التنوع الذي
نمتلكه هنا لدينا
مجموعة متنوعة من
العطور المدهشة التي نقوم بتضمينها في كل جزء من
يومنا وفي كل احتفال لدينا
وفي كل لحظة هناك مثل العطر الذي تم
تضمينه.
مزيج فاكهي جميل هنا ،
لكنني أعتقد أنني سأضيف بعض الشاي ،
لا أنا لا أمانع ،
أعتقد حقًا أن دبي ستصبح
عاصمة العطور التالية في العالم
مثلما أقول دائمًا أن دبي هي ملعب لعشاق العطور.
لم أرَ شيئًا
كهذا من قبل ، لذا الآن سأقوم فقط بصب هذا وأرى كيف
أن
رائحته ممزوجة يا إلهي أحبه
أنا حقًا أحبك